anyway back to movies yeah what what
what were we saying
that was the overall part i feel like
i feel like the oscars just can't win
right now no matter what they do
they're gonna lose like if they if they
if they pander more to
or change the demo and focus more on
mainstream movies the movies people are
actually watching
i feel like the whole integrity of you
know the cause you can't the artistic
integrity
[ __ ] give ten oscars to fast and
furious as much as
you know like for the fact that the the
fact that the harry potter movies never
got an oscar for anything
yeah the whole movie run i do feel as a
bit of a shame yeah because i do feel
during that time
they were just kind of shunned from the
fact that they were seen as just
mainstream garbage
and i genuinely think that harry potter
could have won in certain areas
especially like
you know like uh set design well there
was so many times where harry potter
could have won an oscar oh never yeah
and i feel like a lot of disdain was
built up during that period where
i mean i feel like the oscars just has
not aged well as time has gone on
because like i mean and then they got
caught up in the whole world
culture yeah i felt like when you get
into that debate you've just lost
yeah you're gonna upset someone yeah
because once you get once you get into
the work culture debates
then you you lose whatever side you go
on yeah but you ever you lose whatever
you mean or even don't pander one or
even if you say nothing you are still
losing
you know and i i feel like that was the
start of really the decline of the
oscars along with just the fact that
it's all kind of the same along with the
fact that
the more years i watch the oscars or the
more years i because i
i don't even like watch the oscars that
that often but like more years i watched
it the more years i realized
man i just don't know any of these
movies
[Music]
because i think they had a few years uh
you know where there was a lot of
artsy films that were winning which you
know i'm sure they deserve them yeah but
i think
as a mainstream viewer most people don't
[ __ ] know what that is no
yeah um like what was the what was that
one movie that i
there's there's been a bunch of movies
that have won best picture i'm like what
oh yeah yeah like parasite was the first
movie that one best picture that i was
like i know that movie yeah i've seen
that
good movie yeah um but like a bunch of
other years i've been like what
what i mean i mean i i think the problem
with the oscars for me
is that even if something wins best
picture i mean parasite was one of the
only
best movie winners where i was actually
like everyone was happy though yeah
everyone was happy with that that was
the first time when i saw people
actually happy like mostly unanimously
be like
yeah parasite deserves it it's a [ __ ]
great film because most of the times
when i see a best picture winner
on the oscars i watch it and i'm just
like yeah this is a
this is very much an oscar movie yeah
and i can see why it's so highly rated
but i just
didn't find it that interesting
personally this is what happens
you know there's an institution that
goes on for too long right it's got all
these built up
um you know things that they've been
doing for years like the whole
like if you want to be in the oscars you
have to do a bunch of dumb [ __ ]
and and whole events for the people
doing it and yeah basically pay them pay
them out and
pay them to get in con considered for it
yeah that whole [ __ ] is dumb that's not
how it should be done at all i don't
think any i don't think anybody wants a
system
where to be included in an award show
you have to there's a
pay-to-win potentially i mean obviously
you don't pay to win but you pay to
enter which
i mean why not just make it so that the
best picture
gets nominated yeah you literally have
to like win the heart of the judge
by catering to them not by making
something good
yeah which is like kind of asked
backwards yeah i mean it says something
when i think that like
somehow you know something like the
crunchyroll anime awards is a better
system than the oscars
where they have a mix of like and
obviously if you do fan vote you can
kind of people are still salty
but i think having that kind of fan vote
in the in the equation to say hey
this is what the fans are thinking yeah
just letting you know just letting you
know but also
by making a fan voting system it gets
those fans to actually
watch the show right now no it doesn't
no fans vote for what they watch they
don't vote for every show
on the list no no but what i'm saying is
like they're more inclined to actually
watch the awards show to see who won
if they vote for it i mean they
definitely i'd say more so than
also leaving it to an unknown committee
yeah yeah right to be like this is the
best film
no one can argue about it i mean let's i
don't know how many judges there are
there's quite a lot like 500 or
something yeah
completely estimated maybe ashley can
you check how many oscar judges there
are yeah
i don't think is the exact number known
i'm not sure but i think having some
form of waiting you know like five
percent by the fan or just something
like where the fans can kind of have
some form of yeah like the game awards
right
i mean the game was i feel like i don't
know the exact number but i feel like
it's like 10 percent
is like the fan voted part that seems
good to me that
you know why not at least we know what
everyone else is thinking you know even
if
because i i feel like the oscars is
everything i hate
about pretentious hollywood no because
it's it's
it's putting these people is putting
this work on
like a [ __ ] pedestal yeah where an
award show should be just about like you
know celebrating what everyone loved
that came out in the year
i mean it's become like this whole other
political message and
yeah i mean it's i think that's what
happens when the weight of an oscar
becomes
what it is right yeah you can make your
career off winning an oscar right yeah
if you win one early on i imagine you're
the amount you just start charging
people for your work goes up
significantly yeah yeah so it's
understandable why it all comes in but
yeah it's just i mean that's why i've
always enjoyed other kind of award shows
like whenever ricky gervais holds uh
like host the golden globes that's just
like
that's just like rich people get roasted
4k
like i'd rather i'd take that any day
over the oscars
that's very good i do enjoy that yeah
yeah because the oscars always the same
[ __ ] it's like
and now for somebody who worked hard
there have been struggles
and sacrifices but they worked hard and
won the award
and it's like great this is like as if
as if everybody is not working
yeah you know you could put all the
oscar speeches into
a learning algorithm and i bet it will
predict what the next speech is
genuinely like it feels like sometimes
you know like you you got [ __ ] bra
cause brad pitt did the
speech for best picture uh i know it's
best uh best uh actor i think
yeah or one of them i can't remember
which one um and you know it's like
you have brad pitt and then you give him
this napkin-esque mcdonald's
you know mcdonald's like commercial
speech and it's like
i want to get them to do something fun
yeah why not get them to do something
that will get people interested like to
actually talk like properly i don't know
just yeah
it's just like i don't want to [ __ ]
watch a mcdonald's ad read when ashley
how many
people are in the uh oscar committee the
academy is made up of more than 9 000
voting members
[Music]
so roughly 10 000 people but then
also i do also think if there is 9 000
uh people who are in judging who are
from the film industry
that's also also kind of a problem in
itself right the people who are working
in the industry
are the ones who are deciding the votes
because what because i guarantee none of
them are like film critics or anything
like that right well
i mean yeah exactly that might be film
credit but i mean if there's people who
are working on the films that are voting
i think that's a problem that's a bit of
a biases happening right a little bit
you know
i mean obviously you might i don't know
what the rules are i mean i mean to me
there there is no perfect system
for like an award show right but either
way the way it is now isn't working
either way the way it is now is just not
capturing the
public's like interest interest interest
also why isn't it being live streamed
come on oscars we're in this [ __ ]
21st century live
how do people watch the oscars is it
pay-per-view it's it's on like ustv it's
on tv well why is it not on [ __ ]
youtube or twitch come on i want a pog
champ with the [ __ ]
could you imagine best best supporting
actor and this is [ __ ] monkey s
right before it gets announced you know
like i want that you know like best
actor shrek wins the oscar just [ __ ]
like shrek pogs in the chat like
this would be fun as [ __ ] like what are
you doing this is great
this is how you get people into it yeah
like if you could if you could do
channel point
like gambling because you could do
gamble right like i can do mods mods do
this thing on my stream right
uh do this prediction could you like
imagine if you could do that i bet so
and so i was gonna win
right when they're announcing the
nominations boom the prediction comes in
but pressure channel points you know
what i mean
i mean i feel like this is why the game
is just so much more fun for me
to watch as like a viewer than any kind
of film
film award show yeah or other kind of
award show absolutely you can still
stick all the sponsors in
you can you can fluff the viewership
numbers because they'll definitely be
higher
yeah you can you can do so much more
like it just to me it's like
yeah i mean it's just the whole system
of just old systems in place that
they're you know
have to answer to and yeah just not
bothering to change your system
yeah um i mean to me the oscars has
always been that thing where it's just
been on in the background and people
have talked about it but i'm just like
yeah i mean what was the last time you
cared about who won moscow
i told you it's i don't remember the
last time
i remember the last time i sat down to
watch the oscars
or anything like that where the [ __ ] do
you watch it you're not american like
yeah yeah i mean you can watch it like
back in australia
but yeah not here anymore i didn't even
know where to watch it in the uk
when was the last time you cared about a
winner because i feel like before
parasite i can't even
i can't shrek one of the best animated
pictures i think the last time
actually yeah it did track what no okay
best animated picture i i feel like
that's uh
it's it's either going to be shrek it's
always it's going gonna be either disney
or trick like wake wake me when an anime
actually wins better
spirited one right yeah that's the only
time that's probably the last time i
care about
the last time i was like 2006 or
something like that
2002 surprise was it your name didn't
win anything
it got nominated though did he get
nominated it did get nominated but
obviously didn't win yeah this is so sad
imagine there's pepe hands
yeah i mean like the anime anime has
always just been fluffed by the oscars
no matter what i mean
was it wasn't it that one year that boss
baby got nominated
a silent voice or something like that
i mean i think as well i heard that like
the only reason why i spirited away one
is because
like one of the head people at pixar
like really personally vouched for it
yeah i mean i mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly ghibli is
the only thing that's been noticed by uh
no yeah ghibli's been the only thing
that's been noticed by disney yeah well
because they're certainly like holy [ __ ]
this is better anime than all our stuff
what the [ __ ] what's going on
oh [ __ ] these guys are still doing 2d
animation
that's the [ __ ] dedication right
there yeah exactly ldr nobody cares
about the oscars anymore
yeah until they livestream it and i can
i can do more live stream and then i'll
wait oh but then honestly
honestly i've watched cause then people
would be like if they let people like
live stream it as well and watch it live
man their numbers would be massive yeah
yeah